do you have some old jewelry taking up
space in your home your local second
hand dealer wants to buy it from you
let's head to nevada coin mart
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm neil sac mary my wife and i own
nevada coin mart which is on the corner
of jones and flamingo
i'm the number one buyer in las vegas
when you want to sell your costume
jewelry your gold your silver your rolex
your diamonds you want to go to the
number one person in las vegas
i am a gia graduate gemologist and this
is what i went to school for
the purpose of the business is to
educate and explain
when a customer comes through the door
now what we do
is when a customer comes through the
door we have
six privacy windows that we practice the
six feet social distancing
and so when the client comes in we're
looking at them through the bulletproof
plexiglas
okay so we have a barrier between us on
top of which
nothing ever leaves their sight you want
to make sure you go to somebody that's
honest
that's transparent and that tells you
exactly what it is that you have and so
when the client comes in we're going to
test the items with the x-ray
spectrometer
which is a 30 000 non-destructive
piece of equipment that when you come in
we tell you exactly what you have maybe
you have 10 karat gold maybe a 14 carat
maybe of 18.
we want to evaluate what you have we
don't want to just throw something on
the scale
so when you're downsizing and
decluttering it's very difficult
sometimes
because these are items that you've
collected for your entire life
and so you just want to make sure that
you're getting the best
possible price and so when clients come
in and see me
that's one of the best things that they
can put aside
is they know the transparency of the
business they've gone to google
they've gone to yelp they've gone to
facebook they've looked up the business
they've done their research and what
they found is that we're honest
we're reputable and we're transparent
and so when a client
comes in they want to get the best price
and they also want to do a little bit of
the dance because they love the flamingo
dance
[Music]
flamingos
what i can tell you is this the best of
las vegas is a complete honor
so we won gold and rare coins but we
also won the
unique gifts we also won the antiques
and collectibles
the other one that i won was the best
customer service now
what's important about the best customer
services
those other ones are geared specifically
towards my business
the best customer service goes
for every business all across the valley
and so to be a winner of best
customer service shows something very
extraordinary about the business
and that's what makes the business so
special is that we're not only buying
but you get the experience
for more information call 702-998-4000
or
visit neilbuys.com